[Music]
we should distinguish between accounts
contribution to the epistemologists
person times from council view about the
metaphysics of space and time I wouldn't
buy into cancer deal ISM but I think
that there is a still a kernel of truth
in his account of how we come to know
the world especially in poorer
we need to be very careful about which
kind of time we're talking about whether
we're talking about the time of ordinary
experience which has a distinguished
president moment a sense of flow in a
difference between the past and future
or whether we're talking about time in
the physicists sense which doesn't have
any of those things
I would say that space to the extent you
can talk about it meaningfully is the
order of coexisting facts
[Applause]
well welcome to the soft noon session
time space and being we don't think of
space and time as the core structure of
the universe and it feels on a visceral
level very straightforward yet
Einstein argued that space and time are
the modes by which we think not the
conditions in which we live and it's not
just scientists who've queried this
philosophers such as Kant and Heidegger
argued that space and time with a
framework of our thought rather than the
character of the world so what are space
and time and could it be that space and
time are a form of human fantasy so with
me to discuss this question we've got a
panel is ideally suited to addressing
such a profound issue
michaela MercyMe is a philosopher and
senior lecturer at the university of
edinburgh she would describe herself as
a Kantian and no doubt she'll provide a
bigger picture of that for you today
Michaela is the co editor-in-chief of
the British journal for the philosophy
of science Hugh price is the philosopher
and Bernhard Russell professor at
Cambridge his many books include facts
and the function of truth and Hugh is
also one of the founders of the Center
for the Study of existential risk that's
the investigation of threats to the
existence of humankind and Julian
Barbour is a theoretical physicist and
remarkably julian has made new
contributions to cosmology and to
general therap relativity as an
independent researcher he's author also
author of a book called the end of time
which you'll appreciate is entirely
relevant to today's debate so I'm gonna
give each of them just four minutes to
address the question a space some time
this
structure of the universe and/or a
framework of human thought and then
we'll have the debate in the usual
fashion so let us kick off straight away
with Michaela
the question of whether space and time
are structure of our universe or not is
as you say one of the most profound and
difficult questions in the history of
philosophy some to agustin I used to say
what is time if someone asked me I know
the answer but if I try to explain what
it is then I don't know anymore the
answer and we can say the same about
space in a way spaces will around us we
move in space we pointed directions in
space is the gap between my foot and the
platform of when I board on a train but
if I have to try to give an explanation
of what spaces I found myself exactly in
the same position going back in history
of philosophy some of the most prominent
Minds I tried to give answer to these
questions so back in the 1715 the German
philosopher Leibniz who sent a letter to
the Princess of Wales accusing Newton of
a spreading atheism in England for
defending a specific view about space in
time as absolute space and time as some
empty container that exists and would
exist even if no human beings no object
existed to each Samuel Clarke who took
the defense of Newton replied that far
from spreading atheism in England the
Newton view on space and time was the
best defense for for the importance of
God because we can see of absolute space
and time as an expression of God's
presence in world so Newton thought the
absolute space was the expression of
God's omnipresence in nature and
absolute time was the expression of
God's eternity now that debate in
different forms is still going on in
contemporary philosophy of physics we no
longer talk about Newton absolute time
and space but we talk about the
space-time in relativity and without the
rest of the speakers we'll talk about
that but a debate took a turning point
in the 18th century with Immanuel Kant
Kant was the first one that in my view
clearly distinguished two different
questions one is the question of how we
come to know
about space and time how is it that our
knowledge of the world seems to be
spatiotemporal so we know that objects
are in space and time that's a question
about our knowledge that's a different
question from the metaphysical question
about our space and time real how should
we think of space and time
counter gave different answers to these
different questions so on the first
question on the question of how we come
to know about space and time he defended
in a pluralistic view so against the
empiricists from bar claim to no way to
live beneath he defended the view that
space and times are a priori forms of
intuitions through which we come to know
the world as in space and time so the
metaphysical question I gave related but
distinct answer in terms of the ideology
of space and time and use different
kinds of arguments so he has all sets of
arguments against Newton absolute time
and absolute space including one the
resources to a charge of spin Nazism
which is another very well known
argument it's an argument that he has in
the critical practical reason or the
pure reason or he basically says well if
Newton is right if really space and
times are determinations of God
substance then our freedom is jeopardise
were just automata moving and acting in
absolute space and time so we should
keep those two question distinct because
in my view the answer that Kant gave to
the first question about how we come to
know the world a special temporal is
still very valid and it's an answer
there some studies in contemporary
neuroscience studies on rats and how
higher vertebrates learn how to know the
world especially important seems to
vindicate loosely some contain intuition
about space and times whereas the
question about the metaphysics enhancer
in terms of ideology I think it's a
question that should be left to
contemporary physicists and cosmologists
to answer
there's a particular problem about
thinking about the question as to
whether time is real at the moment which
is comes from the fact that that the
word time has become ambiguous in
contemporary debates and if we're not
careful to note the ambiguity can turn
out that we simply took talking past
each other in trying to address the
question as to whether time is real so I
won't start off by distinguishing two
conceptions of time so that we have that
clearly on the table in front of us on
the one hand you could call it the
ordinary conception of time the only
human conception of time and we can
distinguish a number of elements to that
one is the idea that the present moment
is somehow particularly special people
often say that the present exists the
past in the future don't future doesn't
yet exist the past no longer exists
another aspect of this ordinary
conception is that the idea of the flow
or passage of time there seems to be
something is actually dynamic about time
and another third element of it which is
again subtly different I think is the
idea that the there's some fundamental
sense in which the future is different
from the past so those are all elements
of what we might call our old and the
human conception of time and then in
physics we get a conception of time
which is very different than that in
that at least in the view of most
physicists dueling can tell me if I'm
wrong there's no place for any of those
three elements in the picture that
physics gives us of time so there's no
privilege present moment there's nothing
like a real dynamic flow of time and
there's no deep at the deep level anyway
there's no deep distinction between the
past and the future now but what that
means is that if two people are having a
discussion about whether time is real or
not they may be talking about different
things because one of them may be
defending the reality of time in the
second sense in that in the physicists
sense and the other may be attacking it
in the ordinary sense and those two
things were course perfectly compatible
so what's happened is we've reached one
of those episodes in the history of
science or the history of thought where
we just have to decide how we want to
use a term it doesn't really matter
which way we go we could invent a new a
new word for the
new physicists conception of time
another example where this has happened
is the word atom I mean as it was
originally introduced by the Greek it
Greeks it meant something indivisible
but nobody these days thinks that atoms
are indivisible but we so at some point
we had a choice point we had a choice
about whether to continue using the term
Apple for the the the small things which
were playing a role in in 19th and early
20th century physics well as it turned
out we went on calling them atoms even
though they weren't divisible and we
have a similar choice in the case of
time so when we're talking today about
whether time is real we need to be very
careful about which kind of time we're
talking about whether we're talking
about the time of ordinary experience
which has a distinguished president
moment a sense of flow and a difference
between the past and future or whether
we're talking about time in the
physicists sense which doesn't have any
of those things
well I totally agree with Hugh on the
importance of asking exactly what
concept of time we and in space we're
talking about I'm going to talk about
what seems to me essential for doing
physics and I'm gonna go back to
Michaela started with this famous
correspondence between Leibniz and Clark
who was representing Newton now Newton's
idea of absolute space I think really is
very intuitive it comes from the fact
that human beings developed on a
basically stable earth and in this room
here we have walls that are not moving
relative to each other we can position
things relative to the walls of this
room and we know what we're talking
about it so that's very nice and stable
and somehow rather I you get the
impression that space is there as it
were like an invisible block of ice and
that I think is a fair characterization
of how Newton thought about absolute
space he had very good reasons why he
thought that way now liveness said no
it's it's not that he said space is the
order of coexisting things and it's very
nice he said that in one of the letters
and Clark wrote back
clearly prompted by a new and saying
what do you mean by order and the next
letter
Leibniz wrote he didn't answer that
question so that data from Clark then
says you haven't answered my question
what do you mean by order and then
Leibniz comes clean he says I imagine
there are bodies in the universe and by
order I mean the distances between the
bodies so if I have here three bodies in
the universe I mean the distances
between them and that's all there is
you mustn't think there's a space in
which they're embedded it's just the
distances between that's the only
reality and that's what space is it's
the distances between the things now I
would say that I would change that and
say that Leibniz was on the right track
but it's something different I would say
that space to the extent you can talk
about it meaningfully is the order of
coexisting facts now let me say what I
mean by that
and this is something actually that the
ancient Egyptians the surveyors actually
really stumbled upon because the ancient
Egyptians knew about Pythagoras theorem
4000 years ago so if you drive stakes
into the ground and then you take
measuring rods bamboo canes or ropes
which you can pick up just like that
thanks to nature so here are my stakes
and I can I can measure the distances
between all of these things so if
there's if there's 50 points there
that's essentially 50 times 49 divided
by 2 distances that you can measure
there and that's something empirical you
get facts you get your measuring rod and
you find out what those things are those
are facts and then if a clever
mathematician looks at him you find
something very remarkable if there are
more if there are five or more points
between which you've measured those
distances you'll find they satisfy
algebraic relations certain combinations
of those distances you square them and
you take square roots and things like
that you get something absolutely
magnetic magical a particular
combination of them is equal to zero and
this tells you you've discovered some
very profound order in it and it is that
order which I believe is really the only
thing that is real about space I can
move this thing around and it doesn't
change those separations between it and
actually the overall size means nothing
everything is actually expressed
ultimately in terms of angles so those
original measurements that the Egyptian
surveyors make are the facts and it's
the order the relationships between the
facts which tell us that space is there
and once you've got that what is
wonderful the mathematician can then
place these points in an imaginary space
and and and register them there and then
you can imagine moving them around like
that but actually the facts are
completely unchanged so you wouldn't
think you shouldn't think there's a real
space in which I'm moving this the
reality is it's just those relationships
and if you read the opening page of pure
J's account about how children learn
about space
is actually much the same he saying it's
not nearly as easy as that
you had a very clear account there of
that space is not something that exists
that you won't say exist in reality I'd
like to push the two philosophers here
to say what they what they think space
is Mikayla you gave us a historical
description and cants count that are you
are you wanting to say that space and
time are forms of thought and aren't
reality right I guess the question of
whether I'm gonna concentrate on space
I'm sure time is going to be covered by
hue but let's focus on space when we
asked the question of whether space is
real we need to distinguish different
meaning of what we mean by real if a
real women is space some kind of
substance in the way in which Newton
thought the space was then we're going
to end up with exactly with the debate
that Julian was referring to the base
they are still ongoing in contemporary
physics and philosophy or physics about
what we should think of space as a some
sort of substance or we should think of
space as a bundle of relations obviously
we are no longer working within the
framework of Newtonian mechanics so
we're not talking about Newton absolute
time and space but we're talking about
the space time of general relativity and
how can one be a relational least in
contemporary debates about space so
that's a debate for the physicist but
there is another sense of being real
which has to do with I suppose what you
was referring to as our ordinary
intuitions of the world as special
temporal or what we what Kant would say
our experience of the world especially
important so real can mean mind
independent so here asking me in space
real you're asking me a space mind
independent and so accounting and
response would be to say well no in a
way I cannot be totally mind independent
because Kant would say is an a priori
forms of intuition studies by the 2014
Prize winner John Okeefe and his
colleagues over the past two decades on
the hippocampus have shown how we are
born in a way hardwired to perceive the
world as a three-dimensional Euclidean
space so from very early ages our
hippocampus developed a very
sophisticated system of cell
differentiation that allows us to find
directions in space identify boundaries
distances in space so for example
according to John Okeefe and colleagues
that seems to vindicate some loosely
Kantian view that in a way we are born
hardwired to perceive the world as a as
in space but summary over yeah go
Kantian can any we have to see the world
in terms of space and time we have to
perceive the world in space of time but
it's not somehow out there in an
independent reality is that what you're
saying yeah so say there's a different
question exactly what is it the physical
question do you think that out there
that there isn't space you know in this
independent reality that isn't space and
time no no what I'm saying is that when
is a metaphysical question about no I
understood it once a metaphysical
question and that's another physical
question within I understood that but I
want to push you and say well where are
you going to come down what are you
saying about the metaphysical question
of what's out there oh that's a question
that I'm gonna leave to Joule yes so I
this is request I would say that one of
the typical problems with the content
view is that very often people have been
reading count and the epistemological
question as a question that is
tantamount to a metaphysical question
which is legitimate because that's the
way comes in a way presented his view so
obviously his view is a form of idealism
about space and time what I want to
suggest and this is really my take on
count is that we should distinguish
between accounts contribution to the
epistemologists present times from
Canson view about the metaphysics of
space and time I wouldn't buy into
cancer deal ISM but I think that there
is a still a kernel of truth
in its account of how we come to know
the world especially in Perl and the
first question is a question really not
even for metaphysics it meant the
physician but for physicists but my
question to you is if you don't buy into
accounts idealism which is somehow we
can't say anything about what do you
think about space and time out there I
think that they are and when you say you
point to Julian presumably there are
other physicists will have different
views Julian about space and time Eugen
do you just point to all of these
physicists and say well I don't have any
view about what there is out there I'm
just going to leave it to the physicists
to decide I'm gonna say them interested
in the epistemological question so one
of there's no way I'm tracted to the
current position is because I'm
interested in the question of how we
come to know that the world is in space
and time and and the metaphysical
question is a very profound question but
it's a question that I think will be
better left to whatever the okay and
from from Bisma logical point of view I
think we've got no choice we have to
think of the world in terms of space and
time well that's what I would say yes
okay just a very quick one for me just
in those short your point about us being
hardwired and the experiments the man
who got there we can't with yeah all the
man I've got the Nobel Prize very
recently for the rats having this
picture of their and that it was candy
and I just would like to know and I
don't suppose the experience on these
fish that live in shells and and are
never on solid ground whether they have
whether they're hardwired in the same
way that rats are I think that's an
interesting question because actually if
you stop and think about it there are no
stable walls for those fishes there
particularly after if they're out in the
mid-ocean and all they're doing is
feeding on plankton and things like that
there may not be anything like or the
ones halfway down to the bottom of the
ocean so I think that's an interesting
question just I just wanted to interject
that
so so hew where do you stand on this I
mean is space and time out there real or
not well heal or you you you probably
know the the philosophy version of the
lightbulb joke which are its harmony
philosophers does that take to change a
lightbulb
well it depends on what you mean by
change you know philosophers have this
annoying habit of not taking the words
at face value and that's what I want to
do to you I already so I was in return
trying to actually once we you clarified
the meaning of the words but use them in
terms of the present and the river but
within that what you then want to say
about whether space and time are
independent of us I'll come to the
independent of us cracking but first of
all I just want to start by saying that
one of the things I wanted to say about
space as I said at the beginning is that
we have to be very careful that we're
not dealing with an ambiguity and that
as we look at the the trajectory from
our ordinary conception of space what as
Julian says we may have because we tend
to live in environments with solid
objects things like walls in them if we
move from that to the kind of picture of
space that Julian was offering us in
this one in these elegant mathematical
terms we can if we want you continue
using the term space but we have to
recognize that we've also got the option
to simply talk to invent a different
word and say we've given up on that one
we've decided to use this one instead so
we shouldn't make the mistake of
thinking that there's a single thing
whose essence we're trying to understand
all along so that's what I want to say
about space as I said it about time now
coming to the question of reality of
what's out there I think we have to we
have to have a similar caution about
that kind of metaphor of things being
either out there or not I mean one way
to think about is it in terms of the
notion of the world I think the notion
of the world is a notion that does a lot
of harm in philosophy because people
don't reflect on it enough
here's one thing that you might mean by
out there you might mean the question as
to whether something is true or not is
in some sense independent of us so the
question is to whether it's noisy in
here is independent of our system just
in the moment it's not there's a fact
about that but it's a fact to understand
which we have to think about the fact
that humans have the ears and so on so
there's a there's a kind of human
ingredient in it similarly if we talk
about colors now that's not a that's not
a that's not a sharp divide that we can
put things on one side or the other it's
a it's a continuum and I want to say
that when we are asking the the when
we're asking in blunt terms the question
is something really out there we're
making the mistake of thinking of that
as a sharp bifurcation where it's really
a continuum and what we can say I think
is that the kinds of notions used in
advanced science or the kind of picture
of space that that Julian was giving us
is a lot less infected with
distinctively human ways of thinking
than talking of noise or color on or
smells and so and that's a that's a kind
of clarification which has been going on
for centuries at least since the 17th
century and it's what the the 20th
century philosopher right American
philosopher Wilfrid Sellars called the
distinction between the the manifest
image the ordinary sort of picture of
the world we have in the scientific
image but there's no reason to think of
that as a sharp line and that's the
respect in which I was objecting to the
way in which you were putting that
question so is there anything that you
would want to say with with those
caveats about your two you had two
descriptions of time you gave us to
start with time as the present and time
as the river with your caveat about a
sharp distinction between the real and
not real what would you want to say with
those about the existence or not of say
the time as a river I would say one to
say that the
time is a river thing is much more part
of what cell is called the Mamet
manifest image so it involves our
ordinary human ways of thinking about
time much more than the scientific
picture does so does that mean you don't
think that there is a river of time oh I
think it means you know it there's no
direction of time out there as I know
that so this this is this is where I
want to resist the the sharp division
between what's out there and what's not
because I don't want to end up it in the
position of denying the ordinary sorts
of things that we say like we say it's
now Friday afternoon that's perfectly
true well I didn't make that up that
that's that we can say that's a fact
it's Friday afternoon but but that that
involves a reference to to what time it
is now which is something which is
something that we can only say because
we are kind of creatures who are
embedded in time in a particular way
so one of the characteristics of this
what I was trying to portray as a kind
of gradual gradation for from the the
more human centric concepts that one
into the more scientific concepts of the
other is that at the subjective end we
or the human centric and we we have
concepts whose use depends on various
kind of contingencies about us on the
fact that we have locations in space and
time things of that kind or as Julian
says that the fact that we happen to
live in environments with fixed or what
seemed to us as fixed physical objects
in them whereas the scientific view of
the world is a will a view which depends
on fewer and fewer of those
contingencies but it's basically a
continuum and do you want to privilege
one of those an are all of these just
equipped or alternative ways of talking
about it like that they're not
alternatives in the sense you have to
choose one or the other there are
different ways of speaking and if you're
interested in the scientific project or
finding my way of speaking with which
which sort of detaches itself from the
contingencies of our viewpoint then then
you should you should learn to speak in
the scientific way
so Julian do you do you think there's
anything privileged about the scientific
one space on time I I think science is a
phenomenal success there was a very good
lecture in Oxford recently by Paul nurse
the present president of the Royal
Society where he's saying I mean it
started with long ago before the
Agricultural Revolution with mortality
and things like that and as regards sort
of trying to understand what the world
is I think here is is right we I mean I
think it's very good where he was
talking about the different meanings of
atoms how the meaning of the word atom
has changed and I think if you if we
really want to try and understand what
this extraordinary universe really is
like we just have to look at what is the
best current picture that science is
giving us and and recognize that it's
changing all the time can I come in now
to talk about time however think about
it now loudness I think on one thing I
believe Leibniz was right basically at
the most basic level on time so he he
has space he said space is the order of
coexisting things and I replace that by
space is the order of coexisting facts
and Leibniz said time is just the
succession of coexisting things and I
would say the succession of coexisting
facts and it's very easy to see what he
meant by that if I have a universe which
just consists of three particles I can
imagine that in one instant of time they
look like that and I want you only to
think of the shape that counts just the
shape the two angles determine the shape
of those three particles there but
that's that's one there and then I may
be given I give wonder hue then I give
him the next one and it's a different
shape but I could give you all
intermediate ones that go continuously
one end to the other and just by the
successive shapes I could order them in
in in an order just using the
information in the successive shapes
what I can't do is put a direction on
to it nothing in that we know in physics
actually puts a direction on and says
which one goes in in which order but I
think for me the the liveness is spot on
that you can really think of the of the
universe as just being successive shapes
one after another like that and in fact
if I were to throw them down in a
confused heap there and shuffle them all
nothing is lost the information so it's
just like cutting up a movie into
individual stills I can put them back in
in the in the right order and if it's a
proper movie telling a proper story that
we're familiar with it there will be a
one direction in which you play it we've
all seen these reversed films where
people come out of swimming pools
backwards film was taken as they dive in
and then you just run the film backwards
but there is this is the problem of the
origin of the arrow of time and I don't
know whether I'm not going to give my
talk that I gave it at one o'clock in in
the ring but I think one can begin to
understand that but now I would say I
think there is a notion of now it is
just so to speak that the universe is
like this now that is our now but the
universe is now different and this is
our now now I don't I don't see Einstein
said he was terribly the reason why
Einstein was worried about there's no
place for now was because he denied a
notion of simultaneity but I think there
is a representation of Einstein's theory
where you restore a notion of
simultaneity but you take out size and
you only look at shapes so I think it
will be possible to to talk about now
and I think Einsteins great concern
about there being no place for now in
the modern world view is just mistaken
ah it's always we are in a particular
now and it's it's constantly different
it's a wonderful world
I just want to take Julian up on the
last point there because I want to put
them now towards the more human centric
end rather than towards the more
scientific in the way I like to make the
point is to say look Julian if I if I
ask you to tell me what you did
last week or what the universe was like
last week then in terms of your picture
you'd show me the you show me the
diagrams that represented the temporal
stages of all of the days of last week
you haven't left anything out if you
haven't pointed to any one of those any
one of those diagrams that's
representing the now indeed if I said to
you well you've told me all about last
week but you haven't said which of those
days was now obviously the only answer
you can give is well each of them was
now yes it happened oh absolutely each
the world that the the the posset the
space who was it used this lovely
expression that paid space of
possibilities wasn't used this morning
you know somebody used the space of
positive is George Ellis the space of
possibilities is all possible now and
we're lucky enough to be in one of them
and it's damned marvelous frankly to see
you yeah lipstick wonderfully and
Hillary smiling that is this that is the
space of all possibilities it's all
possible now and we're in and and as one
other thing is this accumulation that
the now is are very wonderful because in
some sense is what is inside my brain is
not only this picture but there's also
pictures of these other nouns that we
think were in the past so they're all
there at once in some senses this is why
I know what she looks like
let me have one word I just I've just
picked up two of these frames that
randomly some frames for our movie as
you said now we want this to think of
this as a complete movie so we want you
to be in the movie not outside it yeah
which of these frames are you in I'm in
both exactly so so neither is privileged
from your point of view
each one is privileged from the point of
view of the particular version of you
which is in that one but that's true as
the one the version of you which is in
that one as well I'm the biggest a ghost
I'm interested in me now if I know I
mean that well perhaps but let me maybe
we're just precisely but but when you
look at the description of the universe
there's no one of those frames is picked
out this is this is the gorgeous thing
there are many Julian's and there are
all of us there are many of us they're
all the experiences they're all the
moments in which we've lived yes I mean
what what I mean that what a cornucopia
of rich you know but in that sense there
were many narrows and knows exactly well
is this I would say this is very
encouraging I mean maybe we are
this is dangerous but are we perhaps
even beginning to move into the divine
where each of our each of our instance
is part of the totality of everything is
one manifestation of everything just
being trying to say no how do we
separate the business of the frames of
thought of a in the Kantian the
description the forms of intuition and
what Julian is trying to do which is
describe what a space and time are in
the independent sense of the physical
character the universe how do we
separate these you you had to version
you know the wanting to separate the the
personal as it were from the insisted
that it shouldn't be seen as a sharp
separation it should be seen as more of
a gradation so so how do we tease these
out how much of how much of Julian's
account there do you think is in the on
the frames of thought theater and how
much of it do you think is to do with
what's going on what I don't know how to
refer to it since sir since you pushing
to me or on describing it as out there
well I I would say that what gave what
what Julian was illustrating by using
these and to illustrate the the the idea
of the the kind of description which his
version of physics would give us of
spatial relations and so on
that's pretty much as far the opposite
end of the spectrum front from the human
centric stuff as it's at this stage
possible for us to be but then when he
wanted to put the now into it I thought
he was confusing that with something
which I would want to regard as being
very much at the opposite end of the
spectrum okay maybe just try let's just
say I mean now
and here's our indexical so the very
moment in which we talk about the now
and here we talk about Julian now here
in this room talking to all of us and it
seems to me that going back to your
question this is the this is the county
and I'm eccentric if you want point of
view that when I will talk about space
and times we have to position ourselves
in space and times now and here are
privileged indexical through which with
our language we do that all the time and
and our ability also I wanted to respond
to Julian about the example of the the
mollusk on the shell the difference
between that and rats and us is that we
have an ability to navigate around the
world so I take that some of those newer
scientific research about special
memories have a lot to do with the way
we think about space and times not as
the physicists to think of them as some
sort of a frame of reference however you
want to understand the frame of
reference in terms of it and the
container bunch of relation but they've
got to do with our ability of located
ourselves in space and time here now and
navigate in space in times my ability to
catch the train to come down from
Edinburgh to say and why my ability to
discern north south east and west my
ability to move in space and time so
that's yeah that's that's my response to
do that here and now may be a way of
trying to get up just a better hand what
we're trying to say here we've got to
ask some so lateral questions one will
be can we imagine something outside of
space and time do you think we can
imagine anything outside this Basin is
there an outside of space and time
well can't said we can think of empty
space but we cannot represent the
absence of space the way we represent
the world isn't special
so there's no I mean would you both
agree with that is there no outside it's
not possible to somehow stand outside
and
again this annoying thing of asking for
some clarification the term outside I
mean there's one way we can take the
term outside where it sounds like a
spatial term outside means it means in
some other region of space other than
the one we're talking about in that
sense of course no nothing can be
outside space it's a contradiction could
maybe have a conceptual sense of outside
well in alternative a conceptual
especially so you might have a
conception of things which were real but
which were not Spacey a temporal yes so
you might think that I mean many people
have thought that mathematics lives in
some other realm which is not a spatial
so do you think there is an alternative
realm which is not one which falls
within framework can we think in a way
which is not within a spatiotemporal I
think I certainly think we can think of
things which are not Spacey oh temple
and I would give numbers as an example
now my own view is it's it's not the
traditional Platonic view that the
numbers exist in plato's heaven that
seems to me to have too much of this a
residue of wealth among other things of
a quasi spatial picture you think even
the numbers having to exist in some
sense somewhere although it's not
strictly speaking in space I'd rather
take a much more relaxed view and think
about how we come to talk that way and
an entire it in with my relaxed view -
about the gradation between the
subjective or human centric stuff on the
other on one hand and the the more or
less objective stuff on the other and
saying yes numbers are a perfectly good
example of something that we talk about
which is not in space and I would say
that the value is another thing that we
talk about so we can think the idea come
we of you know something that's not
temporal yes certainly we can I mean
roughly speaking the only kinds of
things that have to exist in space and
time sort of physical matter things of
that kind but lots of things that we
talk about or not of that kind would you
go along with that
I probably don't have this sophisticated
view of a number say he wasn't so I
wouldn't really know how to think of I
even mathematical entities in in in
those lines I found a hard time to think
of something that exists you can I sort
of slightly change subject can come well
this sounds awfully egocentric but I'd
like to challenge the existence of
whether Julian exists and in what sense
he does the fact of the matter is if you
looked at me microscopically I'm
different I change billions of times
between one second and the next I mean
the hemoglobin read Richard Dawkins
account at the hemoglobin molecule how
it changes how many are made and
destroyed in a split second in our body
it's just and in my book the end of time
I talk about our cat it was phenomenal
it could leap six feet in the air and
catch Swift's in flight and I have to
sentence the cat that left is not the
cat that landed and come back to live in
its liveness has a fantastic vision of
the world which I think for me is about
the best I like first of all he makes
the statement which I don't think is
tenable which all fundamental entities
in the world are sentient beings and he
calls them monads and he says all monads
are just different views of the universe
views of the same universe from a
different point of view
and I would I I go along I think for me
this is still about the best way of
thinking about the universe we each of
us in experience things are we are we
are part of the universe and everything
about this is just part and to some
extent I think it's very true we in the
truest sense we are just part of the
universe I don't and I don't believe in
myself as an autonomous person I find
this very striking when I'm giving a
talk very often I have not the remotest
idea what word is going to come out of
my mouth in two seconds time and a lot
of that is determined by the reaction
from the audience or something I
suddenly recall
from an earlier discussion with Huard
breakfast or something like that I'm to
be quite honest I'm not in charge of
myself I I am a manifestation of the
universe and the the poet's have always
said they don't create their poems
they're just conduits then come five
because you have a strangeness that has
just a bit of the universe you have
tried to provide a description of it in
the description you've just given us so
you have this sort of little bit of self
self reference in the in in the universe
like your your your the standing back
that would just be this one bit which is
some happy mapped on to everything else
in some way which is the self reference
of cry that would be but Leibniz has a
lovely it's wrong I'm being hugely
megalomaniac I'm saying I am the entire
universe but Leibniz has this wonderful
picture of when you're at some distance
from the sea you hear the confused noise
of the waves breaking on on the shore
and and so the real all the details are
at a level where you can't pick it up
easily you can only pick up some things
close to you so that it's that confuse
noise but Leibniz makes the claim we are
literally the whole universe and I think
there may well be a case for that the
fact that if you go back and say what is
what is the information that is actually
determining our universe which solution
of Einstein's equations we live in
actually that predetermines in central
quantum mechanics predictor a large
degree determines what we are so that's
there
let me also end with another lovely saw
and schmuck who's a great hero of mine
who gave his name to the Mach numbers he
said he said we I am utterly different
from what I was a child and he tells a
lovely story when he when he after he
had a stroke and he got into a train in
in Vienna and at the opposite end of the
carriage down the aisle he saw an old
man getting in at the other end and he
said what a decrepit old academic that
is and then he realized there was a
mirror down there and he was looking at
himself
so it's just utterly changed I'm
completely changed from me as a baby but
I I would say in each case in some real
sense we would be more the total
universe
[Music]